>> Laura: YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
AN AVID WATCHER OF
AN AVID WATCHER OF YOU
>> Laura: YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
AN AVID WATCHER OF YO
AN AVID WATCHER OF UN
AN AVID WATCHER OF UNIV
AN AVID WATCHER OF UNIVIS
AN AVID WATCHER OF UNIVISIO
SEE JORGE RAMOS.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> Laura: MY SPANISH IS
SPANISH.
I LIKE TO PRACTICE.
>> I KNOW WE DON'T AGREE ON
ALMOST ANYTHING BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Laura: YOU WERE VERY NICE TO
ME ABOUT MY RNC SPEECH, WHICH
YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T AGREE
ANYTHING IN IT AND I MENTION
THAT IN MY NEW BOOK.
BUT THIS IS THE ONLY THING I'M
GOING TO SAY NICE ABOUT YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN NEW YORK.
A BOTCHED TERROR ATTACK.
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES AS PART OF WHAT IS
CALLED CHAIN MIGRATION.
HE WAS OVER THE AGE OF 18.
HE JOINED HIS PARENTS FROM
BANGLADESH.
IF HE WAS SUCCESSFUL, HE
HE WAS CARRYING A PIPE BOMB.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
HESITATION ABOUT YOUR SUPPORT OF
CHAIN MIGRATION POLICY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND ANY
TERRORIST.
HE SHOULD FACE THE FULL EXTEND
AND NEW JERSEY.
I DON'T THINK THIS HAS ANYTHING
TO DO WITH CHAIN MIGRATION.
IT HAS TO DO WITH LAW
BUT CHAIN MIGRATION IS REALLY
FAMILY REUNICASE.
IT'S BEEN IN THE LAW SINCE 1995,
IT'S CODE WORDS SAYING I DON'T
WANT IMMIGRATION FROM LATIN
AMERICA AND FROM ASIA.
>> Laura: JORGE, LET ME JUST --
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
LET'S DIFFERENTIATE WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT AND WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF 18 WHO
ARE -- WHOSE PARENTS ARE HERE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY'LL BE ALLOWED TO COME IN
AND PARENTS ALLOWED TO COME IN.
ADULT CHILDREN -- STAY WITH
ME -- ADULT CHILDREN OF GREEN
HARD HOLDERS AND EXTENDED
IMMIGRANTS, WHICH HAS BALLOONED
THE NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
61% OF ALL IMMIGRANTS TO COME
INTO THE COUNTRY ARE THE RESULT
CHILDREN, SPOUSES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS.
SO JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND.
>> I DO UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND DO YOU LIKE TO BE WITH YOUR
FAMILY?
DO YOU ENJOY BEING WITH YOUR
>> Laura: YEAH.
BUT I DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO GO
TO ANY OTHER COUNTRY AND BRING
MY FAMILY.
IT'S NOT A UNIVERSAL RIGHT.
>> IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
ENJOY.
I'M ASSUMING YOU ENJOY BEING
WITH YOUR FAMILY.
IMMIGRANTS ENJOY --
>> Laura: THEY CAN STAY IN THEIR
HOME COUNTRY.
>> IT'S UNFAIR THAT WHEN AN
IMMIGRANT, IN THIS CASE COMMITS
A TERRORIST ATTACK ON A CRIME,
THAT WE BLAME ALL THE 40 MILLION
IMMIGRANTS --
>> Laura: WE'RE NOT BLAMING --
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT.
JORGE, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
POLICY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A POLICY.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT BLAMING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HERE IN THE
COUNTRY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A POLICY
THAT MAKES SENSE OR NOT.
BOOKS SINCE 1965.
>> RIGHT.
THERE'S A LOT OF POLICIES THAT
ARE DISASTROUS.
>> BASICALLY IT WAS INSPIRED BY
LAW.
>> Laura: OKAY.
JORGE, DO YOU THINK SECOND
COUSINS --
>> I UNDERSTAND CHAIN MIGRATION.
YOU --
>> Laura: WHERE DO YOU WANT TO
END IT?
FIRST COUSIN, SECOND COUSIN,
TWICE REMOVED?
GREAT AUNT?
THE WHOLE THING?
YOU HAVE A UNIVERSAL RIGHT TO
PICK UP YOUR ENTIRE GENEALOGICAL
CHART TO ANOTHER COUNTRY?
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO END THAT.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAYING
HE'S WANTS TO MAKE AMERICA WHITE
AGAIN.
HE WANTS TO --
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
JORGE!
THAT.
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE THAT.
>> 90% OF THE POPULATION WAS
RIGHT.
IT'S A VIEW OF THE UNITED
STATES --
>> Laura: COME ON.
CHAIN MIGRATION -- JORGE,
HONESTLY.
>> SURE.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> Laura: THE CHAIN MIGRATION
APPLIES -- DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
COLOR SKIN.
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE FROM
SECOND COUSIN OR FROM MEXICO.
THE NEW POLICY WILL APPLY TO
EVERYONE.
LET'S GO TO KATE STEINLE.
YOU HAVE NOT COMMENTED ON THE
CHARGED WITH A MINOR OFFENSE.
HE WAS HERE, DEPORTED FIVE
TIMES, CAME BACK.
WE HAVE A DEAD YOUNG WOMAN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I'M REALLY
I'M A FATHER.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD
MEAN TO BE WITHOUT ONE OF MY
KIDS.
WHEN AN IMMIGRANT GETS INVOLVED
IN A CRIME, AGAIN, THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT ALL OF THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRATIONS ARE
CRIMINALS LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS TRYING TO PORTRAY THEM.
THESE ARE THE FACTS.
IMMIGRANTS ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE
BEHIND BARS --
>> WE CANNOT DO THAT --
>> Laura: ARE YOU CONFLATING IN
THAT STATISTIC LEGAL AND ILLEGAL
>> NO.
PRINCESTON UNIVERSITY DID A
WONDERFUL STUDY -- LET ME FINISH
WITH THIS ONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TALKING ABOUT
PRISONERS ARE ILLEGAL.
22% OF ALL FEDERAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE -- FEDERAL CRIMINALS ARE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THAT'S JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FACTS
FROM AUGUST.
>> BUT IMMIGRANTS OVERALL ARE
LESS LIKELY TO BE CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: WHO CARES?
THAT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S
TRUE, THEY SHOULDN'T BE HERE.
>> THE FACT IS THAT THE MORE
IMMIGRANTS THAT YOU HAVE, THE
LESS CRIME YOU HAVE -- LET ME
GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
WE KNOW, OF COURSE, THAT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRATION HAS
THROWN FROM 3.5 MILLION IN 1990
TO ABOUT 11.2, 11.3 IN 2013.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI, CRIME,
VIOLENT CRIME DECREASED 48% IN
IMMIGRANTS THAT YOU HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE LESS CRIME YOU
HAVE.
>> Laura: I GOT THAT.
OKAY.
>> CRIME AND TERRORISM --
>> Laura: SO YOU'RE FINE WITH
SANCTUARY CITIES, EVEN IF WE
HAVE DEAD AMERICANS OR DEAD
LATINO IMMIGRANTS, SANCTUARY
CITIES SHOULD REMAIN DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THEY PERPETUATE A
SITUATION WHERE ONE, TWO, THREE,
A DOZEN PEOPLE COULD BE GRAVELY
INJURED AT THE HANDS OF AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT?
>> SANCTUARY CITIES ARE CREATED
TO PROTECT IMMIGRANTS THAT
OTHERWISE WON'T BE PROTECTED.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
>> NO, BECAUSE --
>> Laura: WELL, ZARATE WAS
PROTECTED.
>> CRIME DECREASES WHEN POLICE
AND COMMUNITIES AND IMMIGRANTS
WHY SHOULD WE BLAME IMMIGRANTS
FOR ALL THE CRIME AND THE --
>> Laura: WE'RE NOT BLAMING
IMMIGRANTS.
WE'RE BLAMING GOVERNMENT POLICY
THAT IS TERRIBLE.
MEXICO DOESN'T LIKE THAT AND I
DON'T BLAME THEM.
>> THERE'S UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS --
>> Laura: YOU DON'T HAVE A
UNIVERSAL RIGHT TO MOVE TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY WITH YOUR WHOLE
FAMILY OR TO GO TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY AND COMMIT CRIMES.
THERE'S NO UNIVERSAL RIGHT TO DO
LAW.
THEY DO THE JOBS WE DON'T WANT
TO DO AND PAY TAXES AND CREATE
JOBS --
>> Laura: I DID A LOT OF THOSE
BROTHERS.